- カロリーからサイズまで
アメリカと日本のスターバックスの
違いを全て暴いて行こうと思います
その名も、フードウォーズ
＜サイズ＞
- 日本ではホットコーヒーはサイズが４つあります、ショート
- ショート
- トール
＜カフェインパロメーター＞
- グランデ
- 最後に、べンティ
- もちろん、ベンティ
う〜ん
スターバックス回、全部味見していくよ
- 日本では、アイスコーヒーはサイズが４つあります、ショート
- こっちはトールからしかないよ
- トール
- うますぎ、それから
- グランデ
- 最後に、ベンティ
- アイスコーヒーのベンティは
ちょっと違ってくるんだ
アイスのベンティは２０オンスじゃなくて、２４オンスだ
そして更に大きいサイズ、トレンタもある
これは３０オンス 入ってるよ
膀胱に恨みがあるアイスコーヒー好きには
もってこいだね
- それと日本ではこのコーヒートラベラーも販売されています
１２杯分のコーヒー入りです
こうやって開けて
コップをここにセットして
いただきます
Muy bien
- がっかりだよ
こっちのトラベラーボックスはこれなんだ
９６オンス入ってるよ
ここは外れるんだ、いいね
あっちのの方が楽しそう
日本の方が好きだな、こっちなんて
何このつまんない箱、なんだよ
原始人かよ
＜限定品＞
- ここに並んでる商品は全て日本のスターバックスでしか
買えない物です
- そしてこちらが日本の
スターバックスでは買えない、アメリカで売っている商品です
なんてこったい
補足として
スターバックスはカスタムができるから
何千通りものドリンクが
メニュー外にも存在する
TikTokアカウントにも
永遠に投稿され続けている
ということで、今回は日本とアメリカの公式メニューに載っている
商品だけを扱うよ
- 日本ではスターバックスはとても頻繁にメニューを更新するんです
だからこの動画が投稿されている頃には
販売されていないものもあるかも
ごめんなさい
ごめんね
これはGOピーチフラペチーノという商品です
うーん
桃が大好きなんですけど、これはめっちゃ良いです
１０点満点中７点ですね
うまし
GOパイナップルフラペチーノ
ピンクフローズンレモネード＆パッションティー
ちょっと酸っぱいですね
ゆずシトラス＆ティー
最下位ですね
どうしちゃったんだよ
１０点満点中１点
ほうじ茶クラシックティーラテ
ほうじ茶とは焙煎された日本茶のことで
起源は100年前の京都まで遡るんですよ
こりゃぁいい
最高！
１０点中９点には行くかな
チャイチョコレートフラペチーノ
- え？
- 甘すぎる！
エスプレッソアフォガート
アフォガートというのはアイスクリームに
エスプレッソをかけたものをいうんですよね
まぜまぜ〜
- [ﾅﾚｰｼｮﾝ] オメェらのことは知らんがこりゃ
- まただ、甘すぎる
次はダークモカチップクリームです
ごめんなさい、ほとんどこぼしちゃいました
最後の一つは
マンゴーパッションティーです
皆さんのご想像通り、マンゴーの風味がかなり強いです
- もう限界かもしれない
そんな時に頼れるのは？わかるよね？
アメリカは日本ほど
限定メニューが発売されてないんだ
少なくとも頻度は低い
でもこの撮影をしている時期は秋だ
アメリカのスタバファンならわかるよね？
そう、パンプキンスパイスラテだ
秋は必ず
全国民が狂ったかのようにかぼちゃを買って
これも飲む
かぼちゃパイの味がするラテって感じだよ
個性はないけど、やっぱり美味しいよ
アメリカでは新しい
秋メニューが追加されたんだ
それがこちら
アップルクリスプマキアート
試してみよう
なんだこれ？
おいおい、これはひどい
何考えてるんだよ
パンプキンスパイスラテと戦えるとでも思ったのか？
無理だね
もしかして今イカれた人みたいに喋ってる？
めっちゃテンションが上がってる気がするんだ
頑張って極力まともに見えるようにするよ
スターバックスアメリカは、今季...
続いて、フラットホワイト
フラットホワイトとは何か？
エスプレッソと泡だよ
♪フラペチーノ〜 ♪
ストロベリーファンネルケーキフラペチーノ
すっごく甘い
わぉ！
１〜１０で言えばこれは１０ヨゥ！だね
僕の評価システムはこれだ
これが欲しいと思う時間帯が想像できない
WTMOC、何これ？
- [コナー] ホワイトチョコレートモカ
- ８ヨゥだ
チャイクリーム
あぁ、全く
キャラメルリボンクランチ
うん、全然美味しくない
ジャバチップフラペチーノ
まずい！
最後の１個
ありがたや
ダブルチョコレティチップクリームフラペチーノ
しーっ！
他のよりチョコレートっぽくないよ
チョコっぽい名前なのにチョコ味は薄いな
- それから日本限定のお茶もありますよ
これの名前は
ユースベリー
ユースベリーはシトラスホワイトティーで
マンゴー、パイナップル、アサイーがブレンドされてると、ほぉ
ヘルシーなんでしょうね
そしてもう一つは
ほうじ茶です
これは普段よく飲みますよ
朝食、昼食、夕食時、いつでも合うお茶です
日本人みんな良く飲むお茶です
- アメリカではアイスブラックティーも売ってます
日本では売ってないんだね、なぜか
種類は以下の通り
アイスロイヤルイングリッシュブレックファーストティーラテ
お茶って微妙
だからあんまり期待はしてないよ
期待通りだ
次の商品は
アイスロンドンフォグティー
何がフォグ なんだろう
わかんないね
それとアイス抹茶レモネードもあります
それと他に購入できなかったお茶は
アイスグァバブラックティーと、
アイスピーチグリーンティーがあります
ピーチのは美味しそう
コールドブリューとナイトロコールドブリュー
アメリカでは
ナイトロコールドブリューも買えますよ
それから
ソルテッドキャラメルクリームコールドブリュー
バニラスイートクリームコールドブリュー
全部味見するって言ったからには
全部味見していくからね
カフェインに酔ってきたよ
４時間前はおいしかったはず
それから
アイスシェケラートもあるそうだ
名前合ってる？
もしかして今イカれた人みたいに喋ってる？
はぁ、よし
ハニーアーモンドミルクフラットホワイト
最悪だ
プラスチックみたい
- ジャジャーン
こちらはスターバックスオリガミです
スターバックスオリガミは１回用のドリップパックです
１箱には６パック入ってますね
こんな見た目です
まず開いて
こんな感じで
コップの上に置くだけ
お湯を注いでみましょう
お茶の子さいさい、僕天才
スターバックスコーヒーの出来上がり
- リフレッシャーズ
♪リフレッシャ〜ズ ♪
リフレッシャーズとは何か？
僕もよくわからないよ
ジュースに見えるよね
なんか浮いてるものがあるぞ
果物みたいな
キウィスターフィッシュ
違う、スターフルーツ
本当にヒトデが入ってたら面白いね
これはいいよスターバックス、賢い
おー、マンゴードラゴンフルーツ、行ってみよう
うーん
ストロベリーレモネード
美味しい
これはストロベリーアサイーレモネードリフレッシャー
まぁまぁ
アイスパイナップル抹茶
飲みたくないな
- [コナー] やるしかない
- ううん
- こちらが日本のスターバックス
だけで購入できる全ての食品です
大量だ！
- 日本では買えない
フードメニューがこれだ
サンドイッチから始めよう
ターキーベーコンサンドイッチ
ダブルスモークベーコンチェダーエッグサンドイッチ、確か
インポッシブルブレックファストサンドイッチ
ソーセージエッグ＆チーズ
王道のほうれん草とフェタチーズラップ
これだよ
これは
ベーコングーダサンドイッチ
これも買える
アボカドスプレッド
この小さいのは
エッグバイト、ベーコン＆グリエ味
卵白とパプリカ味
それからこれは美味しくなさそうだね
ケール＆ポートベロ味のエッグバイト
要りませ〜ん
お次はベーグルだ
今日買って来れたのは、シナモンレーズン
プレーン味
他にもチーズオニオンガーリック味と
エブリシングベーグル、発芽玄米ベーグルがあるよ
もちろん全て
クリームチーズ付き
- まずここにあるのは
えびアボカドサラダラップ
根菜チキンサラダラップ
根菜サラダチキンラップですね
ペッパーハムオニオンフォカッチャ
ペッパーハムと玉ねぎが入ったフォカッチャです
他にもシーザーチキンフォカッチャもあります
グリル野菜＆ソイハンバーグ
ハンバーグはハンバーガーのパティみたいなやつです
思ってた以上に、合う！
次に進みましょう
卵とポークパティの
イングリッシュマフィンサンド
ハムエッグサンドイッチ
おぉ！
サンドイッチ
チキンとトマトソースが入ってて
めっちゃ良い匂い
次ー！
ぼーん！お〜
おっきなソーセージ
- これはクリスピーグリルチーズ
開くべき？
ただのグリルチーズだよね
パンとチーズだ、分かるよね
トマトモッツァレラパニーニ
ターキーペストサンド
開けるの正解だった？
ハム＆スイスチーズパニーニ
お、チキンカプレーゼパニーニだ
そうそうこれだよ
どうだい
イタリアの国旗がサンドイッチにまで反映されてる
あ〜これは
チキンベーコンパニーニ
開けてみよう
それからプロテインボックスも購入可能だ
種類も多い
今日のお店は取り扱ってなかったけど
チキンキヌアプロテインボウルも買えるよ
- さてこれは焼き菓子・ペストリー類です
最初はこれにしましょう
ビスケットです
それからこのワッフルもある、かなり見た目は良いですよね
あとこの可愛いストロベリーポップ
まるでアート作品、、！
あんことバターが入ってます
小豆は
日本ではすごく人気なんです
変に思うかもしれないけど
日本に来ることがあれば、ぜひ試してみてください
よし次、
これは抹茶のケーキですね
非常に美しい
インスタに投稿したくなるやつですね
レモンケーキ、これも綺麗
チョコレートスコーンと
アールグレイスコーン
これにハリーの顔付けれたりする？
やっほー、ハリー
それから、
ベイクドチーズタルトもあります
可愛いですね
かなり小さくないですか
- ケーキポップ
日本のは大きいね、こっちはちっちゃいよ
ダブルチョコブラウニー
チョコチップクッキー
それから人気の商品なのに
売ってなかったんだけど
マシュマロドリームバーも売ってるよ
クロワッサン
♪クロワッサ〜ン ♪
アーモンドクロワッサン、バタークロワッサン
これだよ
チョコクロワッサン
ハム＆チーズクロワッサン
パウンドケーキと、ケーキ！
バナナナッツパウンドケーキ
これはパンプキンパウンドケーキ
シナモンコーヒーケーキ
シュガーレモンパウンドケーキ
チーズデニッシュ
ブルーベリーマフィン
そしてもちろん
ブルーベリースコーン
ハリーの顔載せれる？
- こちらはパッケージフードです
これはアボカドクリームチーズ味のトルティーヤチップスです
間違いなくビールと食べるね、コーヒーじゃなくて
ビール飲みたい
＜わかる＞
次のは何かな〜
日本語ではこれは
バームクーヘンです
でもこれはドイツ語ですよね？
バームクーヘン？
ダンケシェーン
個人的に気になるのは
この抹茶バームクーヘン
うーん、おぉ！
結構強めの抹茶味がして、すごい好き
ワァオ
僕の人生に現れてくれてありがとう
チョコレート＆ナッツ プロテインバー
で、こっちが
チーズ＆フルーツ プロテインバー
一口かじればたちまち
ハァァア
こんなのもある
ヨーグルト＆バナナグラノーラ
そしてこっちが
ベリーヨーグルト＆ベリーグラノーラ
- これはなんだ
バーベキューチップスに
ヒッピーズ、ひよこ豆だね
ポップコーン
はっ、よし
オーガニックフルーツピューレ
育った木に生やしたままにしてあげなよ
こんな袋に入れずに
アーモンド
おー、コーヒー豆チョコだ
ビスコッティ
マドレーヌ
あと、さつまいものチップス
まだもの足りないなら
ショートブレッドもあるし
ダークチョコグラハム、リップヴァンワッフル、
あとジャスティンのダークチョコピーナツバターカップもあるよ
ごめんねジャスティン、売ってなかったんだ
こちらはデザート類ですね
全部美味しそうでしょ
まずはこれから
オレオクッキーケーキ
シナモンロール
チョコレートドーナツに、オレオクッキードーナツ
ホワイトチョココーティング付き
シュガードーナツ
ベタベタしてる
ティラミスもありますよ
ピーチタルト
そしてこれはレモンタルト
それからこの
バナナケーキ
その次は
チーズケーキ
そして最後に、
ストロベリータルト、とても映える見た目ですが
甘いものはあんまり食べないので
これは全部友達にあげることにします
＜栄養価＞
日本では低脂肪乳を使ったベンティサイズのラテは
205キロカロリーで
脂肪は0.6グラム
炭水化物は30.2グラム
タンパク質は20.6グラム
塩分は280ミリグラム
カフェインは225ミリグラム含まれています
- アメリカでは同じベンティサイズのラテは
170キロカロリーで、脂肪は0.4グラム
炭水化物は25グラム、タンパク質は16グラム
塩分は190ミリグラム
そして150ミリグラムのおいすぃカフェイ〜ンが含まれています
ぷはーっ
- 日本のベンティサイズのモカは541キロカロリーあります
高すぎぃ
- アメリカのベンティモカは450キロカロリーです
そうそう、ベンティモカ
大人用のココアだ
- これはベンティのキャラメルフラペチーノです
日本ではこれは487キロカロリーあります
美味しくなさそうなので
ホイップクリームを追加してみますね
あぁ〜
うぅ〜
いただきます
あーっ
- おいジョージ君んとこの
クリームはへなちょこだな
アメリカみたいにやろうぜ、ほら見てよ
ぼーん
どんなもんだい
アメリカの方がカロリーは低く、470キロカロリーしかないんだ
ストロー持ってきたよ
なんでだろ、全然美味しくない
- 値段はどうでしょう
このベンティサイズのフラペチーノは627円します
アメリカドルで約5.69ドル
ちょっと安くしてくれないかな？
- アメリカではキャラメルフラペチーノは5.45する
日本円で約600円相当だ
かなり近いけど
アメリカのベンティサイズは４オンス
大きいことを忘れないでほしい
計算してみると
アメリカの方が安いね
- これは僕が一番好きなフラペチーノです
抹茶フラペチーノという商品です
アメリカにもこれはあります？
- あぁ、ジョージ
アメリカにも抹茶フラペチーノはあるよ
台本にはなかったよね
さてはうまく騙して
経費で買ったな？
美味しく飲んでね
いただきます
超美味しい、完璧
＜材料＞
スターバックスジャパンは材料を公表していません
ということでカスタマーサポートにメールしてみました
が、今日の時点ではまだ返事を貰えていません
スタバ、何してんだよ〜
ジョージに返事してよ
今のところ分かっている情報は
カプチーノはエスプレッソとスチームした牛乳と
泡でできてるって事です
- アメリカのカプチーノは
牛乳とエスプレッソで出来てるよ
大した情報がないね
全く
既読無視しないでよね、スターバックス
- 日本のキャラメルフラペチーノの材料は
氷と牛乳のブレンド、
ホイップクリーム、キャラメル、エスプレッソです
- 香水みたいな味がする
アメリカのキャラメルフラペチーノの材料は
氷、牛乳、カラギーナン？
バニラシロップ、もちろんコーヒー
それとキャラメルシロップの材料は
砂糖、水、香料、クエン酸、ソルビン酸カリウム
塩、モノ-およびジグリセリド、大豆レシチン、亜硫酸塩です
- 日本のキャラメルマキアートの材料は
バニラシロップ、牛乳、エスプレッソ、キャラメルソースです
- アメリカ版の材料は牛乳、
エスプレッソ、バニラシロップ
その材料は、砂糖、水、香料
ソルビン酸カリウム、クエン酸、コーンシロップ
バター、クリーム、塩、モノ-およびジグリセリド、
大豆レシチン、亜硫酸塩です
日本とアメリカを比べた今回の
動画を気に入ったなら
アメリカとイギリスを
比べたシリーズもあるから見てみてね